warning the following video contains
major spoilers on code gears r2 and may
contain an opinion which differs from
your own if you have not seen r2 cannot
stand bad language or you're just an
annoying fanboy [ __ ] but your discretion
is advised
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what i really wasn't looking
forward to this review partly because
i've never actually planned to review
this in the first place if not for about
half my subscribers simultaneously
shouting hurry up a vrt you nobod and
probably because there is a lot of good
i can say about the show that i haven't
already said i mean all the superficial
things are basically identical so let's
get all the repeated praise out of the
way shall we the soundtrack is still the
same epic suffolk always was animation
is still just as good if not better than
it was in season one and character
designs are still so pretty that they
can make beyonce's ass look like a dog
saggy bollocks cross with amy
winehouse's face or just amy winehouse
voice acting is still great with
maintaining a brilliant job with lelouch
it's morphing time and all characters
still come complete with chin so pointy
that you could probably attach him to
paris hilton's vibrator and use them to
drill to the center of the earth okay so
now with all that praise out the way you
may think i'm being overly harsh in the
rest of this video but that's mostly
because i just don't want to be
repeating myself my first review but as
you all probably know by now i thought
the first season of code gios is one of
the best and most entertaining animes
i've seen and i think that review gave
everyone the impression that i'd just be
rolling out the 10 in the artery review
so i feel like it's my responsibility to
fly in and tell everyone why this isn't
the perfect anime now before you want to
start this video and unsubscribe to me
let me know that i certainly didn't
think arty was bad the first eight or so
episodes were just as entertaining to me
as hold of the first season was and has
one of the best and most epic anime
endings i've seen period seriously this
ending is in my personal top three best
anime endings of all time and that's
saying something but i'm sure you
already knew all that anyway and knowing
that about half my subscribers are fans
of this show i know that i just can't
blindly rip on this anime like i usually
do so allow me to try something
different this one time and actually try
to make some constructive points on why
i think r2 is far inferior to this first
season point one the mecca battles okay
my first point may be my weakest point
since this is more of a personal
preference but the thing i liked most
about the first season were the tactics
and strategies used in the battles are
not the actual meccas fighting
themselves sunrise it seems took this
concept and flushed it down the toilet
gone were the clever tactics that were
decisive factors and victories and said
we would get professor adhd here who
would install some ultra booster mega
gun type supersonic powerful um
thingy that would instantly [ __ ] all
enemy forces within a matter of minutes
and what can only be described as gundam
disorder oh sure they tried to pull the
will over our eyes we're making it seem
like tactics were involved but let me
ask you this did it matter that shin
chaos melted lelouch in china when he
had a nightmare which he seemingly
pulled out of his ass that destroyed all
enemy nightmares in a single bloody shot
did any tactics matter in the tokyo
battle when in the end cannon appears
out of nowhere and wipes out everyone
thanks to the enemy conveniently leaving
the keys right next to the girl for her
to use
exactly point to character consistency
there are many complex characters in
code gears and all the character
development in season one was nicely
planned out but in season two characters
seem to change at the top of a hat with
people doing a complete 180 on their
ideals and natures and changing
themselves for the convenience of the
plot rather than an actual convincing
reason let's take the relationship
between lelouch and rolo for example
apart from his chias he's nothing to me
i'll use you up and then throw you away
like a piece of trash my funeral
offering to shirley will be rolo's life
he will atone for what he did to her you
think you could ever replace not only in
my heart you're an imposter
i hate you i loathe you i despise you
i've been trying to kill you but i just
keep missing the chance i said get out
no stop using your kiosk like that do
you want to die
just what i'd expect of my little
brother
that's right i thought so cause i know
who you really are it's morphin time
your big brother
is just a liar
thank you romo
this big change of heart happens in
about 10 minutes and this type of
complete transformation seems to be
scattered everywhere in the series like
we all know suzaku is a goody two-shoe
who never strays away from his ideals
and will always try to change the system
from the inside and wait what was that
he always said and any ends gained
through contemptible means aren't worth
anything results gained through
contemptible means are worthless yeah
that's the one so we all know he would
never do anything to no i've been naive
up till now no you stubbornly
maintaining that the means are more
important than the end result what
matters are results
brilliant
and i could go on all day about suzuka's
instant alliance with the luch at the
end of the series i mean sure lelouch
maybe you have tried to kill me on
several occasions made the only woman
i've ever loved slaughter hundreds of my
own people and then shoot her in cold
blood but [ __ ] that [ __ ] we're bffs
right so let's all go sing kumbayan
dancing the [ __ ] meadow point three
plot twists anyone who's seen code gears
know that he has a heart of a plot twist
and tries to end every episode in one it
was all nice and dandy for the first few
episodes but after this scene i started
to worry a bit
[Music]
all of them
this is outrageous zero has appeared but
not as expected that is so this was your
plan despite our overwhelming firepower
you figured a way to move a million
people time to get exiled everybody
we're all zero so we're all out of here
that's right i'm zero let's get deported
i'm zero two come on i'm
and things only got worse when they
tried to explain the guillaus aspect of
the show with the whole sword of akasha
business and then the whole charles and
marianne actually trying to protect
lelouch by sending him to japan business
which has so many plot holes you can fly
a jumbo [ __ ] jet through them and
then there's the whole illusion
controlling god business and i really
could go on in the end the problem i had
with the plot twist is that the series
seemed to have this because i told you
so attitude about it marianne
spontaneously developed a gears power
when she was done because i told you so
charles and marianne were actually
trying to protect luch because i told
you so luch is actually a gay sexually
frustrated vampire robot from the future
because i told you so okay that isn't
actually true but you get my point point
four this [ __ ] point five seriously am i
the only one who hates neither this much
i mean shinjikari could drop kick a
kitten into an orphan's face and she
would still be a more hated fictional
character than him sakura ash tay from
yu-gi-oh the entire cast of inuwasha and
kanye west's ego well i could go on
describing the usual force that everyone
else has i.e the excessive fan service
the theatre episode and the cameraman
being completely incapable of pointing
anywhere part of matt cannon's ass
whenever she is on screen but if these
were my only gripes for the show then i
probably wouldn't have minded as much
overall the show just felt rushed which
was disappointing because the first
season felt so well planned out you can
see how the writers wanted to end it
since it has a bloody brilliant ending
but they obviously didn't plan the means
to get there which resulted in
inconsistent character development and
some borderline [ __ ] plot twists
don't get me wrong despite everything i
said i didn't hate the season i'm just
disappointed because i really wanted to
like it because of this i had a hard
time deciding what score to give r2
since there were some truly five star
moments in the beginning and landing
while the middle was just a big letdown
but let's hope this announcement of a
new code glass project will make me
forget about all my frustrations in the
season and okay wait a minute what the
[ __ ] is this i give this anime a seven
out of ten
[Music]
man